Hector: To copy or not to copy?
That is the question from chimpanzees to
the foundation of human technological
culture recently appeared in Physics of
Life Reviews.
Let me see if this works.
Yeah, sorry.
So it all starts with a jigsaw puzzle and
the puzzle is why a highly innovative
species like chimpanzees do not live in a
complex technological world.
So we know chimpanzees are very
inventive, they are very creative, they
are insightful, they can learn socially.
But what we don't see in the same extent
or similar extent we see in humans is the
accumulation of complexity across
generations.
So you can see here in these images we
have one of the more complex and
demanding tasks that chimpanzees perform
cracking nuts open and they can combine
different tools, they can use it in the
appropriate order.
So this means they are very insightful.
And yet if we compare it with a rocket
that can bring civilization to Mars, it
is clear that the accumulation of
technology across generation works very
differently humans and other non human
species.
So the basic question, or the $1 million
question is why does innovation fail to
translate into technological cumulative
complexity in chimpanzees?
Does it owe to a limited capacity to copy
with fidelity or what we referred as true
imitation, which dean reproducing not
only the end result that will be
emulating or emulation, but also the
steps that lead to that end result?
So according to this view, failure to
copy innovation with faithful accuracy
hampers their intra and intergenerational
spread and any ensuing ratcheting up
effects.
So possibly when copying with fidelity is
impeded, innovative performances are
unlikely to leave their protagonists.
And this brings us back to the discussion
we had the other day in the Snakes and
others paper, where we said that after 2
million years ago, iliomo produced these
almond shame bifaciliflaked stones.
But these kind of artifacts that we don't
even dare to call them tools were not
copied by conspecific observers because
perhaps they were not attributing to them
any kind of functional use.
So perhaps they were not seen as tools
and were the result of manual inactions.
So to ratchet up complexity, it is
important that inventions that these
tools are copied with sufficient fidelity
so that they retain the fundamental
features or attributes that make them
functional.
So following the steps of demonstrated
tool manufactured by an expert model to
the letter is the simplest, fastest and
cheapest way to make sure that copies of
the original artifact are accurate as
here cheapest we refer to in terms of
expenditure of energy.
So if the copies are functional, hence
useful, they keep circulating in the
group community longer and this gives
increased opportunities for one or more
individuals different from the original
inventor to add in complexity.
So, for example, one individual invents a
bulldog spur and hundred years later the
smelting of copa is discovered and
another individual adds to it to disperse
a sharp copa point and so on.
So here is an interesting concept of
ratchet effect that would explain in part
why humans have built such complex
cultural and technological work.
So the idea of the ratchet effect is that
no generation starts from scratch.
Instead, inventions and cultural products
created by one generation are kept in
mind and transmitted to the next
generation.
This way, every generation is better off
supposedly, than the one that preceded
it.
So here we can think of books.
Books are a wonderful way of keeping
information, sharing it across
generations and among the same generation
also.
So thus, technological complexity and
success in humans is not dependent solely
on the geniality of one or few
individuals.
It is a joint endeavor where many
individuals contribute their specific
expertise and skills to produce
increasingly complex artifacts.
And again, we can think in establishing a
colony in Mars, no single human alive
could achieve that alone, or would have
the required expertise to achieve that
alone.
But altogether we can perhaps manage
that.
So we need this kind of shared knowledge
and accumulated across generations, of
course.
So why it is some behaviors or innovation
are copied or not can be explained at the
level of social dynamics, but also at the
level of the brain or giving a more
mechanistic explanation.
So explanation of why copinoffs are
behavior and sympathies does not occur
with frequency, have been often kept at
the level of social dynamics where
factors such as social prestige,
dominance, et cetera, are said to be key
to explaining whether or not an invention
is adopted by observers and this approval
against the brain to a subsidiary role.
Here, Michael and I, what we attempt is
to identify what the minimum cognitive
requirements are that can give rise to
innovations and their horizontal and
vertical transmission.
And we also attempted to differentiate
the cognitive ingredients necessary for
innovation from those that need to be in
place for the adoption of an innovation.
So we wanted to establish a clear
demarcation between the brains of the
ones that innovate and the brains of
those who observe an innovation, because
we think this is important to be analyzed
separately.
So in order to see which are the
mechanisms at the level of the brain that
would allow for one innovation to be
copied, we invoked the lens of the free
energy principle according to active
inference.
Under the free energy principle.
It is through there being limited to a
restricted number of states that is the
attracting set that organisms minimize
the variational free energy of the
internal states and resist entropic
dissipation minimizing variation of free
energy reduces prediction sensation
discrepancies prediction errors that can
be corrected by active sampling of
predictive sensory inputs and perceptive
modification ActInf prediction.
This is sometimes expressed in terms of
perceptual inference, that is, changing
predictions to match sensations and
active inference reactively changing
sensations to match predictions.
So innovation, in a way might represent
potential misfirings from otherwinian
perspective.
So minimizing variation of free energy
can be achieved through action sensing
creatures can act active inference in
order to fulfill their predictions and
thereby reduce discrepancy between the
latter and sample reality being limited
to restricted number of states.
What we could refer to as the attracting
set is therefore synonymous with
minimizing variation of energy and hence
maximizing adaptive fitness.
Here innovation represent an anomaly and
innovators are unorthodox actors or
protagonists who entertain new courses of
action or plans new phenotypical
responses that have not been previously
entertained.
And according to this interpretation of
the free energy principle it is at the
level of policy selection where
innovators stand apart from the crowd.
Their policy selection is in a sense
faulty insofar as their ensuing
behavioral outcomes are in mark contrast
to those of their fellow actors who
deploy orthodox responses that reduce
discrepancies between predictions and
sensations thereby reducing the
prediction error.
Here when we talk of misfiring we don't
do it in a kind of negative sense it's
just to express that these new behaviors,
these innovations necessarily will
produce more surprise.
Okay.
Seeing surprising things with this
phrase.
I'm kind of paraphrasing Andy Clark in a
paper in Behavioral Brain Sciences.
He referred to seeing surprising things
to being able to lend credibility to
essential information that is not in
accordance to prior beliefs.
So the family authority density is
entertained by an individual irrespective
to the systems the brains prior bias and
beliefs equivalent, roughly speaking, to
its phenotypical repertoire.
This means by definition that innovative
behavior is both unlikely to be evinced
in any given phenotype and crucially
difficult to recognize when observed by
nava.
Should an innovator's behavior diverge
markedly from ActInf inference of
plausible policies used usually by an
observer to predict another's behavior it
may be beyond the capacity of the
latter's generative model to recognize
it, that is, to make sense of it.
So large discrepancies pose a threat to
the brain because one updating involves
making energetic demands and two risk
reducing adaptive fitness by
inappropriately changing the generative
models.
And here we need to think that the
generative model has been selected also
in a specific economy so changing it
might have risked.
Okay, so what is required for a brain to
entertain generative models that involve
unusual or bizarre behaviors?
The hierarchical predictive
interpretation of the brain or
hierarchically mechanistic mind an
inference machine sorry implies that each
level of the hierarchy of several
neuronal circuits conveys predictions or
conditional expectations that suppress
errors at the level below while
concurrently conveying errors that permit
the revision of the expectations at the
level above.
Plausibly dynamical precision weighting
enables the system, that is the brain to
readjust the confidence afforded to top
down expectations as opposed to bottom up
prediction error.
In other words, in order to entertain a
prior that an unlikely hypothesis might
explain best and behavior weakness it is
first necessary to relax the precision or
commitment to prior beliefs thus enabling
new or impossible hypotheses to explain
novel behavior.
And here I introduce some things we
discussed the other day.
Professor Friston talk of attenuation of
sensory information in relation to
Sacade, which is kind of switching off
this sensory information we are being
aware of and that would be the opposite
as being impressionable.
So I'm quoting Professor Friston here.
If I can copy that means I am
impressionable.
I will accumulate new evidence very
quickly.
I have the capacity to assign greater
evidence or precision to sensory evidence
and suspend the precision to my prior
beliefs.
This is something he mentioned in the
Least Action inference recording 53.1.1
and to end this introduction, one concept
we introduced in our paper which is
central to our discussion is that of
sounds abundant surprising.
So this is a new concept we introduced to
refer to the levels of mismatch between
prior beliefs or top down predictions and
sensory information that a species can
tolerate.
So first and foremost the focus of the
said BS concept is on the observers and
their ability to make sense of unobserved
innovation.
Encoding and subsequent copying of an
innovation depends on the degree of
disparity or surprisal between
predictable behaviors, namely those
typical of the species and the perceptual
incoming information about novel
behaviors.
If the said BS is wide, it means that a
species can give credit to the
information received through its senses
that challenges the prior beliefs.
In short, a species can register, encode
and potentially reproduce innovative
behavior, observing code specifics that
deviate markedly from customary
prototypical behaviors.
The species is highly impressionable if
we use the words that Professor Friston
used the other day.
So if the CBS is narrow, then a species
ability to change prior beliefs to
accommodate new evidence regarding
innovative practices of serving on
specifics is compromised.
I just went up and avoid any kind of
misunderstanding.
Want to make clear that our sons abundant
surprises have nothing to do with the son
of Latin solutions by tena, albeit we are
discussing similar topics.
So the son of Latin solutions that was
introduced by Tania Kai and Tomo Acelo
refers to solutions to a problem, for
instance extractive foraging that can be
achieved by an individual in isolation
during his her lifetime and hence is not
likely to be the product of commodity
culture involving social learning when
observed in the wild.
And for those readers interested in this
concept, they can go to the original
paper I'm showing here.
And also there is recent paper by Andrea
Whiten who is professor in St.
Andrews that discusses this concept and
that has replication by other authors.
So it might be a good update for those
interested also.
And with that I finish this short
presentation and we can enter
discussion.
Let me stop sharing screen I think.
Daniel: Okay now thank you Hector, I will
bring up the notes again.
And to Michael, Carl or Dean, whomever
would like to provide a first response
please.
Michael: Well, I don't really have a
great deal more to add, I think.
Hello?
Daniel: Yes, please continue.
Michael: What's happened here?
Daniel: You're all good?
Hector: Michael, we are here.
Michael?
Michael: Hello?
Can you hear me?
Daniel: Yes, we hear you.
Continue.
Hector: Yes, we can.
Michael: I'm not quite sure what's
happened here.
We seem to have snakes and ladders up on
the up on the screen.
As I said, I don't think I can add much
more to what Hector has just said.
I think it makes a very succinct summary
of our paper.
And I would like to certainly
congratulate Hector for making what seems
to me and a very original and perceptive
observation that it is the observers whom
we have to thank for the copying and
therefore for the handing down of
technological achievements by early
humans.
Whereas too often the emphasis has been
laid on the person responsible for making
a technological innovation.
But of course, unless somebody copies
that, or at least unless it registers in
the mind of somebody else, it is unlikely
ever to get copied.
And although this seems to be a fairly
obvious observation, it seems to have
escaped most of those who have published
on the matter hitherto.
And I think this is a very original
contribution on Hector's pot, which
deserves to be complemented.
And really, that's all I wish to say.
I think I'd like to throw this open to
other people and if I can illuminate or
elucidate any matters, I'm happy to do
so.
But I think this is really very much, to
put it mildly, Hector's brainchild.
And congratulations.
Hector: Thanks, Michael.
You're very kind.
But this is our child and you know a lot
you have a lot to contribute, so, I mean,
I can only learn.
But thank you anyway.
Awesome.
Daniel: Carl or Dean?
Dean: Go ahead, Carl.
Karl: Right.
So I just wanted to reiterate Michael's
admiration for both the idea but also the
very fluent Andy Clark articulation of
it.
It was nice for me to see that presented
so succinctly because the clarity of the
ideas really is really very evident.
It struck me there is sort of two themes
that we could discuss, which is the
emergence of more complicated solutions
to accurately engaging with and modeling
our world.
I think that was a sort of generic theme
in the first part of the presentation.
But then very quickly we moved to this
kernel idea, this core idea that the
dissemination and the transgenerational
propagation that could be read as some
kind of cultural niche construction in a
sort of evo, devo context depends upon
being able to recognize a particular
behavior and thereby copy and imitate.
I think that was the key thing.
And for me, just understanding the
mechanics of that from the point of view
of belief, updating and active inference
was, I think, a really useful thing.
And as Hector beautifully articulated,
the ability to recognize something new
and update one's generative model or
posterior beliefs depends very
sensitively on the confidence or the
precision that you ascribe sensory
evidence in relation to the precisions
with which you hold your pride belief.
And I think that's absolutely crucial.
And I sort of highlight that issue
because it is exactly the same issue that
you will find when applying active
inference from the free energy principle
to psychiatry and the different ways in
which we can I can't remember, Hector,
what was your word?
Misfire in neither a good nor a bad
sense.
But certainly there are certain
psychiatric syndromes that could be
regarded as misfiring.
And of course there's a very close
association with innovation and
creativity and manic depressive psychosis
famed in terms of various historical
figures in the arts.
And that, I think is again brings us back
to this key notion of getting that
balance, the balance of the precision of
our prior constructs, what we have
accrued through experience dependent
learning and the precision afforded
evidence that this is how the world is
actually working and how I am actually
working, getting that balance right.
And that's a really difficult job.
Sometimes in computational psychiatry we
try to explain this in terms of a
statistician.
In order to get the balance right, you
have to be able to estimate these
precisions.
And this exactly the same spirit that a
statistician, when making an inference,
doing a t test, has to estimate not just
active inference in the group means, but
also the standard error.
And it's often much more difficult to
estimate the standard error than it is to
estimate the difference in the group
means.
And that standard error is the inverse
precision.
It's the weight that you afford, the
meaning, the significance of some
quantitative difference, say a prediction
error.
So you see this theme.
There are two parts to inference.
The first order part is just the
prediction error or the surprise.
But then you have to assign how
newsworthy is that?
You have to actually modulate that with
its precision so you can multiply by the
precision or divide by the standard error
to get the actual thing that matters.
That's going to change your mind.
And there's a whole literature on
different kinds of people in the context
of neurodiversity that have an impairment
in being able, or possibly have an
impairment in being able to estimate that
precision.
I'm thinking here of the poster child of
this kind of formulation, which is
autism.
And the idea being that there is an early
developmental failure to attenuate
sensory precision.
So they are, and continually during their
early development, severe people with
severe autism unable to ignore any of
their sensations.
And as a consequence, everything is
surprising, everything is arousing,
everything is in danger of revising any
beliefs very, very quickly.
So they're highly impressionable to the
extent they can't build deeply coherent
models of their lived world or indeed the
other artifacts such as mum, that
constitutes their world.
So I'm just wondering whether a species
that has the same kind of latitude in
terms of either biasing, attention or
precision to sensory evidence versus
accumulated prior beliefs would display
the same kind of misfiring.
So you can go from one end.
An autistic species will be overly
impressionable, it'll be too evolvable,
it won't be able to remember anything
from generation to generation.
The converse is somebody who you can
imagine from a psychiatric perspective
has committed unduly to very precise
beliefs about the way the world works.
And you can think of this in terms of
compulsive, obsessional disorder or
perhaps even depression.
The world is an awful place.
That is true.
Therefore there's no point in going out
and challenging the evidence that the
world is an awful place.
So I guess it's going to stay inside and
feel isolated and not move or say very
much so.
That would be an example who somebody is
not very impressionable.
In fact, their pathology, their misfiring
prevents them from acquiring any evidence
to revise those beliefs.
So if you imagine a species had that same
kind of second order misfiring, this is
not the misfiring of the innovative
sword.
This is a failure to infer the second
order statistics, the reliability, the
precision, the variance, the entropy of
the content of the things that they're
trying to innovate or make sense of.
You're left with this notion of a species
that just cannot respond to selective
pressures.
For selectability, they can't respond by
adjusting their evolvability simply
because they're fixed in their way.
So for the environmental eco niche
changes in any fundamental way, they're
not going to be able to respond to that.
So I think there are many examples of
this sort of key, if you like.
Yes, I think it would be called a
pathology in the sense that in a volatile
environment you would need to optimize
the precision afforded sensory evidence
in order to make the best sense and
understand and engage with that
environment.
And if you get that wrong, there will be
a pathology.
And I think basically Hector's
formulation really drills down and really
focuses on the actual mechanism of this
kind of pathology.
It's all about the transcultural spread
of generative models and sense making in
terms of engaging either with artifacts
or indeed with conspecifics.
I repeat, it's such an easy thing to get
wrong as evinced in psychiatry.
There are so many instances of
neurodiversity expressed clinically that
I think reflects this singular dimension
in terms of the ability to get that
balance, to get that balance right.
And I remember we discussed last time
again in terms of impressionability and
selection for selectability and the like,
the same kind of mechanism unfolding in
terms of evolutionary mechanics.
But at the level I think we're talking
about today, in terms of pursuing plans
and novel ways of doing things that may
or may not be recognized due to a failure
or not of being able to suspend the
precision or prior beliefs.
I think that was a central theme.
I'll just close with an interesting
comment that in terms of the kind of
misfiring that Hector was implying
basically a novel way of doing things,
being the unique province of those kinds
of creatures that can plan possibly
deeper into the future.
There's a really interesting sort of link
back to this precision notion in the
sense that if you try to simulate the
depth of planning of any sentient
artifact, then the degree to which they
are able to look into the future depends
upon the precision of their beliefs about
the succession of contingencies.
What will happen if this happens and then
what will happen if that happens.
So just technically the precision of the
transitions amongst worldly states of
affairs as you roll out into the future.
And again, you have to estimate that
precision.
So there's another, if you like, point at
which precision gets into the game.
But in this instance it's not the
precision of the sensory evidence but the
Markov decision about the ways things
unfold.
And what will happen if I do that?
If you have a low precision there, then
you don't plan very far into the future
because you lose certainty and confidence
very, very quickly after just a few
moves.
Whereas if you have very precise beliefs
about the state transitions and the
consequences of various actions or
sequential policies, then you can roll
out confidently much further into the
future and perhaps find that innovative
solution.
So again, we come back mechanistically to
phenotypes that have differing degrees of
precision in this instance get into the
game in terms of bounding the depth of
the planning or the temple horizons that
you can entertain when scoring different
plans in order to actually select the
best action at the moment.
So for me that insight is really useful
because I can see how one could simulate
that quite easy easily in sort of toy
situations.
So those are my thoughts inspired by
Hector's.
Excellent presentation.
Daniel: Thank you.
Carl.
Dean, what say you?
Dean: Well, if it's okay, I'd like to
sort of step back for a second.
And because we were privileged to be able
to look at the two papers almost
simultaneously, I know chronologically
we've split it up into weeks but as
readers we were able to kind of look at
both papers side by each.
I kind of want to take a bit of a
Hofstead or strange loop two sided
condition mobius we've got that all those
representations in a lot of our live
stream introductions.
So if we were to assume that because Carl
pointed out, not everybody can
accommodate two things at once
perspective, if we can assume that, that
doesn't overwhelm my question to the
authors is do they see their own
journey?
As a one paper or artifact artifact
morphing into the next or and as we were
pulled out and taken up by this
relationship between epistemic and
pragmatic values when uptaking an active
inference perspective?
That's part one of the question.
Part two is the former is kind of a
sequential, mechanical, technical side of
things.
The latter is the combinatorial plus
meaning entailed and entangled.
So more where am I relative so combined
that's a relative depth of field as
setting, as establishing morphing, we
want to call it that as active inference
strategy is applied.
How do the authors see or potentially see
this perspective combining meaning the
sequential and or the combinatorial
affecting not effecting but affecting
what we believe?
Because I'm a big believer that we can't
just sort of strip the feelings part of
this out.
I think that's whether we're talking
chimpanzees or whether we're talking the
emotions of sliding down a snake those
are part of this thing that we're looking
at.
Daniel: I'll just give one short note on
that in the paper sophisticated affect of
inference.
They simulated counterfactual futures
projections about futures which are
inactive inference, action oriented.
All futures are analyzed and inferred
about with respect to policy selection by
the agents.
And one of the patterns already apparent
in even the simple simulations were that
even if a very small fraction of
counterfactuals have like death as an
outcome or highly negative outcomes it
can increase the variance estimator on
possible futures greatly leading to
essentially ruminative behavior and
affective anxiety around the legitimately
warranted variance in possible outcomes.
So I see a key piece of this puzzle to be
entertaining progressively wider time
cones of possible futures in a
prospective capacity and entertaining
progressively wider time cones in the
past of causal mechanisms and somehow
negotiating that affect barometer in the
moment as the eye of the needle.
Hector michael, where do you see affect
coming into the snakes and ladders to
copy and not to copy set?
Michael: Well, may I make one or two
comments?
First of all, in addition to what
Professor Fiston has told us about autism
and so on, I think it's worth mentioning,
in the connection of the question that
Daniel has just raised, to say that there
is clearly a difference in the evolution
during the life cycle of early humans on
the one hand and great apes and probably
most human forerunners on the other.
The extension of the human life cycle,
the extension beyond childhood, and in
particular, as I mentioned last time, the
adolescent growth spur to which we have,
but which may not have existed in early
hormone, even one and a half million
years ago, I'm sure is relevant to making
the evolutionary step between, let us
say, the surprise that perhaps a
chimpanzee has if she observes a dead
bird and then regards this as
counterintuitive.
Because birds ought not to be lying on
the ground throws it up into the air.
But this is an individual spontaneous
reaction which is not handed on as part
of a behavioral repertoire amongst the
species.
And on the other hand, when we begin to
see the reproduction of, as it were,
counterintuitive behavioral sequences
such as taking a lot of flakes
repetitively by hand from a piece of
stone using another stone to produce an
almond shaped hand axe fairly regularly
flaked on both sides.
Something which is not found before homo
appears in the archaeological and
paleoanthropological record but which is
not something that seems to be a regular
part of human behavior.
It is almost as if the individual who
made that was doing it as a kind of
spontaneous thought of what might happen
if I was to do this part of the deep
generation of the hierarchically
mechanistic mind which Professor Friston
has told us about.
A deep generation that, however, may have
been a misfiring.
It may have been simply a person
spontaneous event which is not easily
recognized by others, particularly if
their, shall we say, to put it mildly,
their mental development is stunted due
to the early adulthood and the lack of
any adolescence, adolescence in
particular.
And, of course, the development of the
neuronal architecture of the brain which
in modern people continues until our mid
20s.
If this was not to have occurred, as it
does not, of course, in even in great
apes, then there would have been perhaps
a problem here about the deep, generative
potential of an individual ever being
recognized, such that it isn't just what
might happen if I was to do this with a
piece of stone, but what might happen if
I was to copy what that other individual
is doing with a piece of stone.
And this, I think, is the stumbling
block.
This is what has led to the snakes and
ladders picture.
It is what I think has led to the very
slow adaptation of technological
cumulative technological handing down
from between generations or between
individuals of a generation and between
generations.
And it may well have been the case that
it was not until demographical as well.
Of course, as paleobiological changes had
evolved in the Guinness homo that there
was sufficient intercourse not merely
sexual but social such that these
questions continued to be asked ever more
frequently and with the appearance of
better and ever more fluent communication
would allow what we now regard as human
culture.
Specifically human nature which I think
has differentiated us ever more from the
great apes.
Those are my thoughts on the matter.
Daniel: Thank you, Michael, Carl or
anyone else, please.
Karl: Can I just speak to the question
about affect and what Michael has just
treated as two?
So one way of conceiving of affect and
valence and the emotional aspects of
choosing different plans or making sense
of my own bodily sensations is to think
of it in terms of precision estimation.
So one way of a very generic way of
thinking about negatively effectively
charged states of mind would be those
states of mind in which there is
irreducible or unresolvable uncertainty.
So to put simply, to be uncertain about
what is going to happen to me or what I
should do is to be in a state of angst.
And that can be linked to notions such as
anxiety and with some extra nuances,
other feelings such as a low affect and
indeed if that is pervasive a low mood or
depression.
But I think the key thing here and indeed
many people have developed a calculus of
emotion based upon whether your average
level of uncertainty is increasing or
decreasing or is high and low and adding
these things together to get an ontology
of emotional states or a purely sort of
inference perspective.
There are another body of thought and
literature which links emotions to the
literally gut feelings interception so
that certain emotional states are just
hypotheses about the way that I am
feeling now that best explain the myriad
of extraceptive interceptive sensations.
So I think there is a mechanics of affect
in certainly interceptive inference and
possibly more generally in terms of
active inference.
However, there is another aspect of
things that we the feelings that we might
associate when we feel compelled to do
things.
And I'm thinking here not about the
irreducible or irresolvable uncertainty,
but about uncertainty that can be
resolved.
I'm thinking here when Hekter mentioned
Andy Clark's treatment of surprise, there
is also the truism that we expect to be
surprised and technically that can be
explained in terms of the imperatives for
choosing those actions that will resolve
uncertainty about the way the world
works.
So this is just an expression of
novelty.
So if we anticipate, if we anticipate
that we are going to be surprised by some
outcome, what we are saying is that that
outcome is going to be informative and
that it will reduce some uncertainty.
Technically it has a high expected
information gain.
So I'm speaking here as a statistician
and using terms that would underlie the
Bayesian principles, optimal experimental
design that we do these experiments
specifically in order to get surprising
outcomes that are by definition going to
resolve my uncertainty about my different
hypotheses.
So if we think about the misfires that
are innovations, these are effectively by
definition novel behaviors and they are
the fact that people or certain people
and certain creatures engage in novelty
seeking is entirely sensible from the
point of view of the free energy
principle because novelty seeking just is
an expression of curiosity.
It is just an expression of choosing
those outcomes that are going to yield
rich information that has technically a
high self information or an expected
information gain.
So this is another view of, if you like,
the effective aspect that we are
compelled and expect ourselves and will
possibly explain ourselves as being
excited in a positive way and the
opportunity to resolve uncertainty
because we see an opportunity to do
something novel.
What is behind that door, what is inside
this present?
What would happen if I did that?
And that's an entirely natural and by
natural I mean something that is easily
naturalized under the physics of self
organization of any system that has or
entails an implicit generative model of
the consequences of its own action.
So I thought it was a lovely link between
that kind of affect written into the
imperative to seek novelty, to seek
surprises in the future, and what Michael
was saying about well, yes, in order to
do that, you have to suspend your prior
convictions because if you a priori
think, you know everything.
There is no novelty, there is no
imperative for expiration, and you just
do the same thing time and time again.
But if you can recognize that there is
reducible uncertainty and choose those
actions that have the greatest expected
information gain, then you will
necessarily succumb to novelty seeking
behavior and thereby discover those
misfire innovations.
And it may be that the story that Michael
was telling was that we are built to be
curious creatures for much longer.
We are built to be able to respond to
novelty and to find those innovative
novel ways of behaving so that we remain,
we retain that childlike curiosity as
part of our epigenetic epigenetic
neurodevelopmental programming for much
longer than other species.
So I think that matches very nicely with
the basic thesis that Hector was
proposing during the presentation.
It all comes back to getting the
precision of your prior beliefs, right
and suspending very precise prior beliefs
in order to explore hypotheses.
And that exploration just is in terms of
engaging in novel innovative behaviors
that you know, will resolve your
uncertainty.
So if that's right, sort of engenders a
question why is there an evolutionary
pressure for this kind of eternal
childhood?
So I want to ask Michael and Hector,
because Michael had certainly brought in
language and cultural niche
construction.
My guess would be that there will be a
circular causality between the cultural
eco niche and the phenotypes that trying
to adapt to that cultural eco niche such
that they are required.
Or the phenotypes that have the greatest
adaptive fitness are those that retain a
greater curiosity in the context of the
culture in which they find themselves.
And part of that will be necessary to
actually understand the communication and
the signs and the semiotics afforded by
their conspecifics, which could be read
just as language.
So my question is, did this innovative,
does innovative tool use, does it emerge
stochastically or at certain points along
with communication and language, or are
they not correlated?
And if they are correlated in terms of
historically, what are their thinkings
about the direction of causality?
Does the fact that you remain curious and
innovative for much longer lead to
language that we can engage in novel
communicative behaviors?
Or is it that we need to remain curious
and open minded in terms of thinking
about or entertaining novel plans and
innovative plans simply because we have
to make sense of a world that is rich in
information because there is language
that has been culturally inherited?
Or is it both?
Is there both top down and bottom up?
Causation so two questions language, tool
use and copying and the coupling between
the sort of evolutionary and the
phylogenetic and the sort of phenotypic
levels when it comes to things like
language.
Michael: Well, I wonder if I could come
in here, Daniel is it okay if I address
Carl's questions?
Daniel: Yes, in whatever order you like.
Michael: Thank you.
Well, in the first place, there is a
voluminous literature on the relationship
between language and the origins of tool
making and tool use, really.
And there's a lot of unresolved argument
about whether the two came together very
early in human evolution.
Let's say between 1 million and 2,000,001
and a half million years ago, as I
originally thought some years ago, or
whether in fact, language as we know it,
or shall we say fluent communication at
least only developed much later, as I'm
coming out to believe now.
And as Noam Chomsky has said for many,
many years, I don't want to get involved
in that because really we would need two
or three programs and a lot of literature
to compare and contrast.
Rather, I would query whether we have an
eternal childhood.
On the contrary, I think that
physiological, childhood is slowed down.
And when the adolescent growth spurt
arises after about the age of, let's say,
nine years old at some times, or perhaps
somewhat later at others, is when we see
a major change in behavior which is no
longer childish, but neither is it
adult.
Of course, we need to go into that.
We all know that adolescents can be very
impetuous but they can also be extremely
anxious.
And this brings us to the angst that Cole
has mentioned, and which I certainly felt
as an adolescent facing the weekly driver
voucher examinations in human anatomy in
the dissecting room, which in those days,
we all had to undergo, at least in the
United Kingdom, as I can sure call the
members and which always put me into a
state of extreme nervousness and has
given me a lifelong worry about the lack
of accuracy, let alone precision.
In anatomical description and
identification and a concern with the
statistical variability in human anatomy
or aspects of it, or anatomy in general,
necessarily human and its relation to
process.
In other words, to physiology.
And I feel myself much more, despite
having lectured in human anatomy much
more aligned to physiology and I spent
some time doing neurophysiological stuff
many, many years ago at Oxford and in
gettingham then in the classification
this has to be that way.
And as we were taught as medical students
always think, Doctor, about the most
obvious rather than the most obscure.
But we have to have the whole range
before us.
And this brings in the whole problem of
do we think in terms of very right or
wrong, concrete facts about stuff in
general, or do we think in terms of the
statistical Lagrange of variability,
whether it is in terms of occurrences,
let's say, related to quasant type
distributions, or to continuous
variables, which can be, let's say,
related to gaussian type distributions.
And unfortunately, it was only much later
in life that I discovered that in fact
modern statistics allows these two
approaches to be compared and contrasted
in a uniform manner.
I didn't know that 50 years ago, alas,
which shows my ignorance.
Still, I would come back to the whole
business of the growth curve of humans.
This clearly has altered when we look at
chimpanzees and other great apes,
basically they don't have much of
anything approaching our adolescence.
They don't have this slowing down of
growth.
And then a recuperation of the velocity
of growth combined with, most important,
not merely anatomical and physiological
changes but also those of the mind.
The ability to innovate, the ability to
have lateral thinking or the ability
which I have noticed in some young people
I've met with Asperger's Syndrome, to be
able to concentrate in great detail on
particular matters which are
extraordinarily arcane, such as Sanskrit
literature in people.
That are not of a South Asian heritage.
Whereas in dealing with other people,
their other colleagues, they appear to
be, shall we say, gauche.
And this is of course well known,
however, and indicates the range of
variability.
But it is the change which we all undergo
in not merely physical, but also
intellectual ability and inquisitiveness
which could get us into trouble when we
are in our adolescence and as young men
and women.
Given the continual and continuous
changes in our Neuronal architecture, at
least until our mid 20s these days, which
I think distinguishes and has
distinguished the evolution of Homo in
general and Homo sapiens in particular.
But I wouldn't rule out Neanderthals or
even Homo erectus and which I think has
been cumulative and undoubtedly, although
we have no idea, undoubtedly enhanced by
increased and ever more complicated
communication during the past probably
half a million and certainly quarter of a
million years.
This curiosity what would happen if we
did this?
What would happen if we did that?
But even so, things are not rapidly
grasped and we see that in different
parts of the world, particularly in
modern populations even that have been
long separated from each other, not
everything is developed at the same
rate.
A couple of well known examples are.
For example, the wheel which first
appears probably on the Eurasian Stephen
about 5000 years ago and was used for
traction and then appears quite
independently in pre Columbian
Mesoamerica about 2000 years ago and was
not used even though it would have been
very useful for even anything as simple
as a wheelbarrow.
But simply to move around images, whether
they were dolls or toys or gods, we have
no idea.
And another one, taken from the same two
areas of the world is the metallurgy of
copper, which appears about, well,
perhaps over 6000 years ago in Eurasia
and possibly 2000 years ago independently
in the New World.
And yet other things happen too.
For example, in Australia we find modern
people were making hand axes when these
had long ceased to be made by anybody
outside Australia.
Some of them may even be only a few
thousand years old.
So this appearance and disappearance and
reappearance is something which has not
gone away and must be related somehow to
our ability for this deep generation of
our inquisitiveness, our curiosity, and
indeed, our ability to not to see the
most obvious thing around us the desire
to see only one simple solution which so
irritated me when my teachers in
department when I was a medical student,
believed that there was only one right
answer as to how many heads this muscle
had or how many vertebrae there were in
this or that part of the vertebral
column, let alone in the skull.
And we know how very variable these
matters can be.
So there is this tension between the
desire for things to be seen in one light
only in a one dimensional way and our
natural inquisitiveness this deep deeply
generated desire to say what would happen
if it was like this?
How has it come to be like that?
Why is everything different and not the
same?
I can't put it any other way with that
I've said quite enough.
Daniel: Thank you Michael Dean.
Dean: Thanks Daniel.
So again, this is for the authors.
This has been really helpful to me as
observers because that's highlighted very
clearly in the papers.
I see both papers speaking to something
that I would describe as condition set
meaning in the papers.
Examples limit the game to the game
metaphor at least to this type where
there's a limited number of tiles and a
clear continuation until a conclusion or
recognize the limit of the species to nut
cracking.
So there's a real clear idea and Michael
and Hector have both spoken to so what
was the growth limit of the brain's
capacity, et cetera.
What I'm curious about, and I don't know
if there's Michael or Hector or have a
real clear answer to this but I'm
wondering what and when was maybe the
range of time that we see the unlocking
or sort of combinatorial explosion or
not?
I guess what I'm asking is is there a
move that we can clearly see as being
something that differentiates playing
which we know happens in a lot of species
and gaming?
Because as I said at the end of 53.1 I
wondered if it was going to be game on.
And so I'm curious what the authors think
about is there a difference between
playing and gaming?
Meaning that there's now an actual
introduction of strategy in this?
So maybe another way of asking is is
there a moment when you guys can point to
it and say this was kind of when we saw a
reducing or maybe a relaxing of a limit
forward world.
Michael: I wonder whether in fact, this
difference is really quite as great as
Dean suggests and whether it maybe have
something to do with the ability in
working memory and other aspects of
memory in dealing with or in developing.
Logical mathematical ability to plan or
in planning and in communicating this
ability such that the planning is no
longer on an individual level, but is
participatory, and therefore a game.
In other words, and perhaps Hector can
answer this question but I would suggest
that this developed slowly, gradually and
by no means in a continual, let alone a
continuous manner in homo but not in
earlier in a way not in earlier and other
hominid species do we see?
And this I would ask Hector do we really
see, let us say, chimpanzees or other
great apes developing the kind of logical
math ability to make very simple
combinatorial associations between
objects or behavioral activities and
developing this into a communal game
which involves other individuals in the
group.
Because, as Hector has remarked on
various occasions and informed me when we
see things like nut dragon in small
groups of chimpanzees, it by no means is
copied by all of them, let alone copied
or emulated by all of them, and by no
means even when it is with faithful
accuracy and precision in the manual
operations that are required.
So I would ask Hector, do we see these
associations being transformed into
games?
Hector: Okay, that's a tricky question.
What we know with chimpanzees is that
they have promised to do these second
orbital relationships which is like
hierarchical ordering of for instance, if
I have a set of objects, I can classify
them attending to the color, for
instance.
Jims could do that, okay, if only color
is involved.
But I can classify them by color and
shape.
So this is another order of hierarchy.
So I can pick things that are square and
red and put them together.
So this ability to abstract a kind of
ordering category so that I have
relations of relations like in analogic
and reasoning when I can focus on one
dimension or in another simultaneously so
I can shift my focus from one dimension
to another in order to classify things.
This, I think, is quite human like for
instance, the Wisconsin Car Shorting
test.
So I can shift from one dimension to
another to classify objects or cards.
And this is something that chimps would
have more problems to do.
So they might classify in a first order
categories.
Like I put things that have same color.
They could learn to do that.
That wouldn't be a big problem.
But I guess if they have to use two
dimensions together to classify their
objects they would have more problems
because this involves considering more
than one dimension simultaneously.
I'm not sure I'm making sense here.
This is the Jonas Langer work that he did
it with kids and that's remarkable work
that Jonas Langer did.
And then there were these people in Rome,
I think it was Poti at the lab of biopark
in Rome that replicated that with
chimpanzees.
I think it was Espinosi who replicated it
and found that chimpanzees were more
compromised in order to have this kind of
classifications of relations.
And I think that's a very remarkable
ability that we develop.
So I don't know if I answered your
question, Michael.
Daniel: Perhaps that comparison of two
dimensions, color and shape and then the
snakes and ladders overlay that lets us
take the hypotenuse is that abductive
jump enabled developmentally and neuro
epigenetically by all of these different
features which happen over much slower
timescales especially considering the
actual millisecond timescale associated
with recognition.
Those other changes are so much slower.
But the ability to move diagonally on the
grid through the rows and the columns and
turn that into movement on a manifold is
the ability, looked at from the either
row or column perspective to move in both
at once.
But by condensing those two dimensions
into one there can be new kinds of
cognitive movements and then applying
that cognitivist lens also evolutionary
transitions even without the complex
cumulative feedback with the ecocultural
niche merely in the abductive moment.
And just one other piece I wanted to
return to is that every variable can have
a precision estimator or not in the
generative models, in active inference,
every variable can be fixed.
And so the model can just be persistently
surprised with no updating.
Or one can have any kind of prior or
hyper prior and so on.
And that enables learning.
And that's what enables not just
estimation of the mean or the center of
gravity, the expectation of but also the
variance, the whole distribution.
And then by applying that kind of
precision on everything view which, as
Michael brought up, is exactly what
modern statistics does you can't do
inference with a Ttest unless you have
the mean and the variance won't go into
any more details on the statistics.
But every variable has the center of
gravity, mean estimator and the variance
estimator.
And so we talked about precision on
sensory information the mapping between
observations and hidden state estimates.
And then also there's this action action
oriented representation, how things will
unfold.
And you might be able to update your
precision on sensory evidence by seeing
something different.
But updating your precision on how things
will unfold is oriented around taking
actions.
Dean: Daniel, you must have some
questions.
I can't be the only one floating
questions and having my zone of bounded
surprise of being expanded here.
Daniel: I have questions.
I can ask you a question.
Or Michael or Hector.
Or Carl.
Please feel free.
Hector: If you would like to pick up with
something that Professor Priest mentioned
before that was kind of intriguing
because it is true that some great
artists like Bangkok and others were very
creative and also I don't know if it's
appropriate to say they were in the verge
of psychosis.
I don't know if it's appropriate because
I don't have any statistics.
But I'm thinking is being innovative is
this again this misfiring?
So I would like to separate two things.
One is how innovative you are.
And I'm thinking in the echoes, if you
are well adapted to an environment, it's
not a good idea that you try different
things all the time.
Because imagine that you have some place
where there are nice berries, you have
discovered a safe path to that place and
if you keep to that path, you go to the
berries, you get there, you feed, so
that's good for you.
Imagine you want to try something new.
So you are very innovative and one day
you decide to try another path to the
berries, a shortcut.
So you have one risk that you can face
new dangers because this path is new, you
don't know what is waiting for you
there.
The other risk you face is that you can
get lost and then you could spend the
energy you need to survive.
So in a way I don't think that being
innovative is good in itself, but we have
the risk if we are too conservative that
the environment changes and if the
environment changes significantly, we are
not well adapted because we don't have
alternative behaviors that are adaptive
to the new environment.
So I guess with this happens like
psychological traits, nobody has
extremes, so we don't have people with
extreme psychological personalities.
I mean we have pathologies but the
selection has favored kind of
intermediate levels.
And Professor Fries and correction on
this, he knows more about
psychopathology.
But I guess it happened with innovation
that we need some kind of balance.
And what is intriguing for me is how
humans escape that balance in terms of
how they manage to be creative and
innovative at times because we repeat
many routines but still we can be very
creative and we have selected so we have
been successful enough to our echo
niche.
And I'm just thinking in this conte
factors idea.
So I think this might have played a major
role, the ability to have conte factors
because perhaps instead of risking my
life every time I innovate, I can
rehearse what will happen.
And as Professor Friston mentioned
before, if I have a good precision, I can
imagine things that will unfold.
If the genetic model is very deep, I can
think ahead many steps and see how I will
fare in the future.
So I can kind of rehearse things in my
head before I put them into practice in
the real world.
And it might help me to be innovative but
with a kind of bounded risk or control
risk.
I don't know if this makes sense, but I
think it must be some kind of balance
between if I can rehearse things in my
head, I'm very good and predicting things
that will evolve or unfold many steps
ahead, I can see how I will fare and then
I can risk to be novative.
I don't know I mean, I'm being very
speculative here, okay?
So I just want to make clear that I'm
being very speculative.
Karl: Please.
Daniel: Carl?
Karl: Yeah, I'd like to speak to that.
Yes, you may be speculating, but I think
those observations are very vertical and
very useful.
I mean, you've brought a number of
fundamental issues to the table.
First of all, the importance of being
able to plan to have a generative model
of the consequences of actions is not the
gift of all species.
And in some instances, in your words,
when the environment doesn't change, that
would be an undue complexity cost to
carry around a brain with a generative
model of the consequences of my actions
if I don't need it.
If I was a virus or an insect, I wouldn't
need that.
It would be very inefficient.
So that sort of lends or brings you to a
picture that our world is sufficiently
complex and changing at pace.
Committing to very simple, underlying
expressive generative models is not an
option.
And one really important way of making
them more expressive is to increase that
temporal horizon or temporal depth so
that we can, in accord with things like
simulation theory, roll out into the
future and now become the kind of
phenotypes that can select among a number
of plausible policies.
And I think that would be one bright line
between lots of different genres and
different species that could be just
drawn on a dimension, which is just the
depth of planning that my generative
model will support.
And we talked previously about that being
constrained by the precision afforded in
a given context my beliefs about how I
would roll out into the future.
So I think that's just from my
perspective at least, that's a really
important observation that the depth of
planning is a very important functional
characteristic of the generative models
that are implicit in phenotypic behavior
and possibly in terms of what kinds of
models are subject to selective pressure
at an evolutionary or indeed at an eva,
divo level.
The other, I think, key insight that you
bring to the table here relates to what
affords the right balance between novelty
seeking, exploratory behavior and the
risks that that would entail.
And I think that from a purely sort of
mathematical point of view, is a really
important observation just to sort of
join the dots with other ways of
understanding how the universe works.
That particular question is very usefully
framed in terms of constraints.
So the free energy principle from which
ActInf inference inherits is one way of
or is dual to something called the
maximum entropy principle under
constraint.
So this was brought to physics in the
20th century by a foundational thinker,
E.
T.
James, who basically rewrote physics in
terms of probability theory and said that
basically everything of interest, at
least physically conforms to a
constrained maximum entropy principle.
So that actually is just an expression.
Or tends the free energy principle in the
sense that the constraints, from the
point of view of free energy principle
are just what is brought to the table by
a generative model and the entropy
pertains to the entropy of belief.
So you've got this dialectic simply at
the level of the physics of measurement
and inference, which means that I'm
always trying to explain any measurement
such that my predictions are as accurate
as possible, but at the same time having
the maximum latitude so that I don't
overcommit in accord with Ockham's
principle.
So mathematically, what that means is the
entropy of my beliefs has to be as big as
possible, provided provided I have an
accurate given the constraint, that my
account or my measurement has to be an
accurate measurement.
So that may sound, if you like,
completely unconnected to whether I
choose to wander away from the Berry
path.
But in fact, exactly the same math
supplies to these quantities either the
constrained entropy or the variational
free energy in the future.
And what happens is you get exactly the
same dialectic.
You have two pressures, on one hand, to
comply with Ockham's principle or
Ockham's razor, and on the other hand, to
keep all your options open.
Which, in a sense is exactly do I comply
with the constraints that I know I'm
going to get my berries and I'm not going
to be eaten myself by a predator?
Or do I keep my options open and try that
other path?
So this whole dialectic is just baked
into the physics of any self organizing
system.
And practically it emerges in a number of
ways.
One way of writing down the free energy
or the constrained entropy, from James's
point of view, expected, given a
particular policy, do I go down this path
or that path is in terms of ambiguity and
risk, using exactly your words.
So the risk is just the relative entropy
or the divergence or discrepancy between
what I think will happen and what I
expect to happen to me.
So I expect not to be eaten.
And that's the key constraint at hand
here.
So it's not about rewards anymore.
We're throwing away the notion of
rewards, and we're now replacing it with
a multidimensional construct, which is
all the constraints in the ways of being,
like having a certain temperature or not
being very cold or very hot, not being
eaten, not being dead, just keeping
within my characteristic states.
So you write down those characteristic
states in terms of constraints, and those
constraints basically preclude certain
states of being.
And then I just compare, what will my
states be if I do this, and how far away
is that anticipation from my prior
constraints?
And that literally is called risk.
It's the KL divergence between your
policy dependent predictive posterior and
your prior preferences that have the
constraints.
The other thing is the ambiguity.
And that simply reduces to making sure
that you make moves in a way that
underwrites an unambiguous precise
mapping.
Between what you see and what caused your
sensation.
So you avoid dark rooms basically you
avoid the dark, you avoid dark alleys,
you don't go where you can't see what's
happening.
So that's the ambiguity.
So together the expected free energy is
equal to risk plus ambiguity.
And when red light that then the balance
between the risk and the ambiguity.
Or another way of carving this up is in
terms of expected information gain and
expected cost or its complement expected
value where the value is just to what
degree am I complying with my
constraints?
Enables you to now write down the balance
that resolves to a certain extent
dissolves that dialectic by the precision
of your prior preferences, your
constraints.
So if you're the kind of creature or
child or insect that has very precise
beliefs about the kinds of outcomes I
expect to anticipate and I may have very
precise beliefs about my body temperature
for example, but I may have very less
precise beliefs about where I am in terms
of latitude.
I could be in Alabama, I could be in
Newcastle and London, I could still be me
but I can't be two degrees centigrade and
still be me.
So some constraints are very precisely
specified and other constraints are less
precisely specified.
So the risk is determined by the
precision of your prior beliefs about
your characteristic states, the precision
of the constraints you bring to the table
as a phenotype and some of these will be
innate and completely subpersonal.
It's wired into your homeostasis.
Some will be learnable, some may even be
sort of oppositional, we can talk about
them but whatever they have to be there
because they define basically what kind
of thing you think you are and how you
act accordingly.
So the balance between whether to go down
another path as opposed to the berry path
is going to depend upon this particular
creature of phenotype and specifically
the precision of their prior preferences
in terms of what outcomes they would a
priori entertain.
And if they have very very precise
preferences over not being eaten and
there's even a marginal small probability
of being eaten if they stray from the
current path, then they won't explore.
If, on the other hand, they have a
slightly more liberal expectation about
being about the encounters with a
predator, for example, then they will be
more likely to engage in novelty seeking
and exploratory behavior.
Perhaps put this even more simply, this
is the exploration exploitation dilemma
ripped in terms of the physics of self
organization under planning and it all
reduces again to precision.
And in this instance it's the precision
of the constraints articulated as your
prior preferences, your characteristic
states, the kinds of states that you
believe characterize you, that if you
stray from you cease to exist basically.
I don't think what you said was
speculation.
I think they're all fundamentals of
behavior and actually from an
ethnological perspective they speak to
the heart of choice behavior and why we
do the things we do and why it is always
in the background, the game of saying do
I explore or do I play it safe?
Daniel: Awesome.
Thank you, Carl.
Dean: Dean, think you're muted, Daniel.
Daniel: Thank you, Carl.
Go ahead, Dean.
Dean: I just like to run with what Carl
was saying.
This is mostly for Hector and Michael
here's a case in point.
All the collective wisdom on the side of
a volcano can suddenly be arrested and
yet there is still a pompeii today.
I wonder what you gentlemen think that
says about certain species zone of
founded surprise.
Daniel: Dean, does this refer to the
fixed materiality alone of the ruins of
pompeii of which no more will ever exist
in the archaeological context, being able
to be unpacked into this collective
wisdom?
Dean: I'm just curious because we are
talking about regular irregularities and
regular irregularities, these seismic
events occur in the timeline and I'm just
curious what we think then as we reflect
on that and still adopt that kind of risk
mindset.
As I said, I would just want to run with
what Carl was suggesting.
I don't know that there's an equivalent.
I don't know if chimpanzees would do what
humans have done, like see the evidence
and still park themselves right in the
path of danger.
I'm just curious what they think about
that in terms of the timeline aspect of
this.
Daniel: Hector or Michael?
Go ahead.
Dean: I think you're muted now, Hector.
Hector: Sorry, my Mika is off.
So it's a kind of difficult question.
Dean, I'm not sure if I understood
correctly, but as you're referring to the
tone of bandager price and linking what
Professor Christian said before, if I'm
to take any road, which is I don't know
what awaits for me there.
Okay.
But if I'm very good at making guesses or
inferring what might happen based on
information I have gathered before, so
I'm good at anticipating what might
unfold.
Okay.
Because I have this complex machinery,
let's call it working memory, which is a
construct, I have a powerful working
memory, so I can entertain many
possibilities.
And there is something that kind of
ringed a bell when Professor Friston was
talking of precision, which is the
concept of metacognition.
So metacognition refers to thinking about
my own thinking.
Right.
And it has two clear aspects.
One is how sure am I about my knowledge?
For instance, I'm sure I know something
even when I cannot remember.
This is the tip of the tongue effect.
I can give you an answer and be 100% sure
this answer is correct.
I can be 80% sure, 50% sure, so I can
evaluate how much sure I am about
something.
Okay, so this, I think is really a bit
like precision.
So if I make some expect plans and I
think what might unfold, I can be very
sure this will happen or not.
And this probably has to do with my
metacognition.
So how sure I am about what will happen
and that might help me to decide whether
I go or not.
And coming back to your sonoband
surprise, I'm not sure if I'm digressing,
but perhaps I can preempt this surprise
if I have a good precision or good
metacognition.
So if I'm sure that I can rehearse things
in my head and see how they will unfold,
they won't be that surprising later.
So I'm just speculating perhaps this
ability to have contractors, to have this
kind of rehearsing in my head and this
depth of generality models can preempt
your surprise.
And here I'm speculating clearly.
So I don't know if I answer your question
about pompeii because I'm not sure I
understood, but just bring some ideas
that might be useful.
But again, they are speculative.
Karl: It'd be nice just to link that
notion of metacognition and having
beliefs about beliefs, the precision of a
belief about the likelihood of being
eaten by a predator.
I think that's what Daniel was speaking
to before when he was talking about the
hierarchical depth of models and their
increasing complexification.
One really important way of making a
model more expressive and context
sensitive is to induce a hierarchy of
exactly the sort that Hector was talking
about in terms of this metacognitive
aspect, but not just content, but
crucially, again, coming back to the
confidence and the precision, I think
that's a really central concept.
I was just thinking, if you had to commit
to what kinds of epigenetically specified
constraints you would associate with the
genome, in what space would they live?
And my guess is that most of it is about
the constraints, and within that it's
going to be the constraints on the
precisions, that there are certain sort
of innate ranges of outcomes that I will
entertain.
And in principle at least, you can
actually just write down an entire
generative model in terms of constraints
and in terms of precisions.
In the sense that if the generative model
is universally expressive and everything
goes, then you can sort of carve out an
apt structural form for that jarrative
model just by shrinking some of 99.9% of
this overly expressive, generative model
to zero with very, very precise
constraints.
Perhaps I'll turn this into a question.
If you were trying to simulate artificial
life in its most generic sense, if you're
trying to simulate tool use, for example,
the emergence of tool use in a synthetic
population, and you had to actually write
down what could be asked via genetically
or epigenetically to each subsequent
generation, what kinds of things would
you specify?
Dean: That's kind of my question.
In the same sense, where do we draw those
arbitrary lines?
I mean, it's the thing that comes up
again and again as we continue to sort of
see the next sedimentary layer of papers
discussing this, right?
But the fact that it can be moving and
the fact that there is a rate constant
that you mentioned in the last Livestream
that has to be working, functioning and
effective.
And then there's still this question of
what are we attending to and what are we
still available to all at once and how do
we organize that in a way that it most
closely, as you say precisely that's the
best way of describing it, what's really
going on.
And that seems to me at least to be a
moving target.
Daniel: Just one quick speculative
mapping as well.
First, instead of just stacking bricks
with content on content on content
intercalating layers of content
estimation with metacognitive estimation
is what allows the extendability of the
multilayer predictive processing type
architectures.
It's actually like the back and forth or
the interplay between the content
estimators and the variance estimators
that allows that model to not just be
described in terms of its center of
gravity but also in terms of its full
distribution.
And then to Carl's question about what is
being passed down genetically and
epigenetically and thinking about those
terms even generically like in the
context of perhaps source code and a
configuration file or some other mapping
of what is inscribed from a classical
information genetic perspective and then
what is contextually and more rapidly
transmitted?
There's an interesting angle I could see
it this way or potentially the opposite
but there's a shorter term epigenetic
firing rate and then a slower updating of
neuromodulatory like genetic
possibilities kind of opening and closing
valves over a slower timescale and then
of course these are nested within another
one.
So this can also itself be a firing rate
in other ways but just focusing on this
direction the inscribed constraints are
like the width of the aperture and then
the actual flow of the photons through
the lens is an instantaneous firing rate
that's happening way faster than the
aperture can be dilated or not.
And so merely the fact that there are
multiple concurrent timescales and the
associated interplay of their rate
constants tells us a lot about this kind
of learning architecture.
What we do without understanding is the
action question and related to our
preferences and precisions.
However, it seems pretty key that to
alternate estimates about content with
metacognitive type estimates and to
package that set of two belief
distributions dean invariants to package
those also as one so it can be handled as
a composite one.
Karl: And just to point out that learning
rates are the manifestation of that
second order specification, that
precision.
So they are the same thing at every time
scale.
So you could articulate the developmental
stages for example, use the word
rejuvenation but certainly the changes
say in late adolescent as a programmed
learning rate for learnability that can
be read at some level as a precision
because the precisions are just the rate
constants that link the state to the rate
of change of state and that basically is
just a learning rate at many, many
different levels.
So I think there's a sort of uniform way
of putting together these different
notions.
Some useful notions here from machine
learning are sort of the notion of
learning to infer.
So I was just thinking about an answer to
my own question and clearly you can't
write down a generative model that's
going to be able to get up and go to
school in the morning.
All you can do is to create a self
organizing Blob that has exactly the
right learning rates so that it has
exactly the right learnability so that it
can acquire a generative model and learn
through experience dependent plasticity
that model of its little lived world.
Of course, that little lived world has
been constructed by other grown up
babies.
So we get back to this circular causality
that evolution is trying to provide you
with the right ability, learning rates,
precisions and structural constraints on
your generative model.
But your generative models, from
evolution's point of view are actually
creating the environment that has to be
learned.
So to my mind there's a very beautiful
circular causality here.
As fast as you're learning, you're
actually creating new worlds in which to
learn.
I guess we're seeing that at the moment
with advances in technology and the
like.
Which brings me back to my question about
the sort of the top down versus bottom up
causation about what is a good model of
this world, what is a good phenotype?
Daniel: In our final 15 minutes or so
here, how do we move beyond the 53.2
either to the authors, their directions
and excitements about the work, or
anyone's exhortations or raising of
possibilities for other ways it can be
developed?
Michael: I wonder if it's worth bearing
in mind that increasing technological,
not necessarily complexity, but at least
variability may well have permitted a
reduction in selection pressure on the
phenotype and evidently affecting both
the genotype and epigenetic variability.
I say this because I would like to draw
attention to the graph which I presented
last week, which was taken from Professor
Philip Tobias work on early humans,
showing an increasing range of variation
in the cranial capacity of bipedal
hominids from the australopithesines
through to Homo sapiens, suggesting a
reduction in selection pressure for
particular well, for the size of the
brain.
Basically, I find it hard not to relate
this to the advantages that slowly accrue
to tool use and thereby, of course, the
variability and variation of tool making,
thereby reducing the risk, or some of the
risks, existential risks.
That otherwise plague or have plagued are
the homininins, whether extant, whether
the ancestors were extant great apes, or
indeed the earlier forms of bipedal
hominin ansaurs, of pithes, Paranthropus,
Kenyanthropus, et cetera.
Well, who knows?
But it's perhaps not totally irrelevant
that this variability has grown over the
past couple of million years and is now
very wide.
As I mentioned last week, this, I think,
is in contradistinction to the way in
which selection pressures have been
highly discriminatory in, for example,
producing, let's say, the wide range of
Darwin's famous Galapagos finches, just
to give a well known example.
Daniel: Thank you, Carl.
Karl: Coming back to this theme of
selection for selectability and the
notion of precision or learning rates
cast in terms of mutation rates.
So my favorite example of and I'm sure
there are better ones nowadays when I was
reading around this subject, my favorite
example was the story told by Ernst Mayor
about Drosophila fruit flies being reared
in volatile versus non volatile
environments.
So you're rearing generation after
generation at a fairly fixed temperature
and then an equivalent set of generations
where they varied the temperature a few
degrees plus and minus.
And what those showed was that the
mutation rate of the Drosophila in the
volatile changing environment was greater
than the mutation rate the genetic
mutation rate in the less volatile
population or transgenerational
populations which I thought was a
beautiful example of selection for
selectability itself.
That increased variation, certainly, or
its phenotypic expression of implicit
increased genomic variability was itself
an adaptive response to the rate of
change of the environment.
So my question is, is there a similar
sort of picture or view of variation in
either phenotypic or genetic
characteristics over a longer time scale
in sort of human evolution?
And if there is, is there any evidence
that there is in the past century or so,
perhaps this is a bit of an ambitious
ask, but is there any evidence that there
has been a sort of phase transition in
the variability and the evolvability and
the associated phenotypic variation?
Daniel: The empirical or an empirical
research agenda would be to make a
hierarchical active inference model and
perform dynamic causal modeling on
different variability characters across
levels of phenotypic and genotypic
integration and have that model in use.
But a very provocative and interesting
question, Carl.
And to what extent is it happening with
our cellular architecture?
And to what extent are these processes
happening with our niche, given these
unique, cumulative cultural generative
model generative, process thinking
through other minds, increasingly the
production of artifacts that enable not
just offloading, but outsourcing these do
represent unique cognitive niches.
And so it will be quite interesting to
investigate, perhaps if we each want to
have some closing round thoughts, perhaps
Dean, with the first word thank you.
Dean: Because you know I hate having the
last one.
Karl: I'm just curious.
Dean: Gentlemen, thank you first again
for your generosity.
I'm just curious, now that you've dipped
your toes in this active inference
institute Livestream world, what are your
impressions?
Was it helpful at all?
Hector: Who is next?
So I think it has been very useful and
mostly very fun.
I mean, I've enjoyed a lot to have this
discussion with all of you, so it's been
very enjoyable.
And just for the future, I'm just
wondering if there is such a thing like
preempting surprise based on these
counterfactuals.
I guess maybe it's already written and
discussed and it's all clear, but I
wonder that this might be an interesting
idea to explore if I can preemptive
surprise before I act, before even
acting.
But that's kind of maybe that's resolved
already.
Anyway, it has been fun.
Thank you all, honestly.
Daniel: Thank you.
That makes me think about saying, I don't
mean to surprise you, but that's actually
going to increase.
It's like, oh, boy, has someone been
injured?
But what is the show not tell of
preempting surprise?
So that with a linear string in time,
there is the path from the old berry
patch to the new berry patch such that it
appears to be within a nested
hierarchical model, the path of least
ActInf to follow, though in a less nested
model, it would be quite surprising.
Michael or Carl, your kind of closing
thoughts or questions as we bring this
set of 53 to a close.
Karl: Well, I'll let Michael have the
last word and just speak to what you just
said in Hector's comment.
I think there's a lot of interest in that
notion sort of trying to preempt
surprise, a simple reading of risk
minimization.
You're just basically not engaging in
policies that are going to result in
surprising outcomes, where surprise is
just a violation of prior preferences.
At that level, I think that sort of
almost a truism.
But there's an interesting sort of
implication of that which leads to
notions of the way that we choose to
behave epistemically in terms of avoiding
information that would be very
surprising, sometimes articulate in terms
of optimism bias, sometimes in terms of
wishful thinking, but the kind of paradox
that you get when we are Bayesian optimal
creatures.
And yet we don't want to open the letter
from the GP giving us our most recent
cancer results.
Or we don't want to open that letter,
find out whether we fail to get that job
or pass that exam or indeed the anatomy
dissection vivor.
There are certain things that we avoid.
There are certain surprises that we
avoid.
Put it another way, there are certain
ways of preempting surprise by avoiding
knowing stuff that we might find
surprising.
And that's an emerging literature now,
which takes you a little bit outside your
comfort zone, but it's a fascinating
literature.
You'll find things like trends in
cognitive science and the like in answer
to Dean's question about these sessions,
because this is not my first session, but
this does exemplify it.
Yeah, it's for fun.
We're amongst friends and indulging
ourselves and those people who care to
listen to us.
So I think the next thing to do is the
next horizon.
Although I do think dynamic calls and
modeling of evolutionary trajectories is
an excellent idea.
I suspect the heavy lifting now is to get
the ideas that we've been talking about
out there.
I think that's what Michael and Hector
have to do, basically, is just keep on
telling the story.
And in my experience, it usually takes
about five to ten years before people
start listening.
Daniel: Thank you, Carl, Michael, with
the last word.
Michael: Well, these sessions have been
fun and most illuminating.
There is a lot to be done on the whole
matter of whether there have been phase
transitions in the evolution of what we
might call evolvability in again as homo
over the past 2 million years.
There are big arguments amongst human
evolution specialists between whether
there was a unitary evolutionary whether
a unitary evolutionary model is
acceptable, or as lumpers like myself
would like to believe, or whether, in
fact there was a big bush.
With a lot of dead end, separate,
unsuccessful species like
Homoflorisiensis, Homo, Luciano.
Hector: Or.
Michael: Even perhaps Neanderthals, with
whom I've had a lot of contact, having
excavated about 15 of them.
And these arguments are highly relevant
to the matter of cognitive evolution and
indeed as to whether the record of
artifacts and tools can indeed inform us
that I believe it can about just how and
how slowly I would say, evolution
proceeded.
Of course, the splitters believe it
happened in leaps, jumps and leaps.
I'm rather convinced Darwinist, I believe
that things happen very, very slowly and
that we have to concentrate.
And with this I conclude on especially
the neuro epigenetic modification of
genetic expression as affecting not
merely morphology and physiology, but
also, I would say, cognition.
And in the matter in hand, of course, the
ability or not, that our supplysals
affect onlookers and other people
permitting, let's say, modification of
behavior with far wider results than
those that occur in many other species,
including some of those of our closest
permanent relatives.
Thank you very much for organizing this
session, Daniel and Dean.
It's been a pleasure to take part.
I'm sorry that I have this terrible
appearance, but I really can't do much
about that at the moment.
I hope.
Well ask for a few days.
Bye.
Daniel: Thank you all.
Dean: Michael, at least you have an
excuse.
I have no excuse at all.
All right.
Daniel: Till next time.
Long live the mean.
Long live the variance.
Hector: Thank you.
Bye, everybody.